only on this broadcast we are proud to
announce the 2018 Teacher of the Year
this exceptional educator will spend the
next year as an advocate for more than
three million teachers and 50 million
public school students across the
country no small task this year's winner
we are proud to announce is Mandy
Manning she was chosen by the nonprofit
Council of Chief state school officers
based on her effective work inside the
classroom Mandy teaches English and math
to refugee and immigrant students at
Jolie Faris High School in Spokane
Washington she is often the first
teacher they have when they come to the
United States and we are excited to have
Mandy here this morning but first we
spoke to a number of her former students
about her impact all right so we put you
in your language groups again because
you're going to help each other so when
I came to request I think I only know
how to say hi cuz I was so nervous I
don't want to talk to people miss
Manning taught me confidence because
that health helped me with a lot that I
am today
I didn't believe I could do it but she
made me believe in myself
what's your dream what's your dream I
always wanted to be a doctor but she
hired me she convinced me to do it so I
am a cosmetologist because of her I got
my first job with her help she don't
care about where you come from how you
like your background is she just told me
she's still helping me with my difficult
assignments that's a great message
like what make her different he's like
her wanting to be part of the student
life she made me feel like oh there's
someone behind me which is miss Manning
just a lot of love I want you to come
back
Mandy Manning welcome and
congratulations I love watching you
watch that video because your eyes just
light up watching your students teaching
is so hard but what's the what's the
lesson that you try and impart just that
students are particularly my students
since I teach immigrant and refugee
students that's they are wanted and
welcomed and they're capable of anything
and that they should you know whatever
they believe they should work toward and
do I was looking at some of the things
you wrote here list all the countries
some of your students are from Oh
Afghanistan Iraq Sudan Uganda Congo
Ethiopia Eritrea the current state and
Burma Myanmar Micronesia to Malaysia
Malaysia how many of those languages do
you speak because most of them speak a
little or no English so how do you
navigate the language barrier well I
speak like I speak Japanese in Armenian
which aren't usually helpful in my
classroom so but you know they're all
brand-new English language learners and
I serve anywhere from 12 to 14 students
languages within my classroom so the
common language is English so we just
start with the foundation the basic
skills and move from there and and your
students a lot of them have been through
extraordinary traumas too it's not just
that they don't know the language yeah
yeah they have they've been through
quite experiences that no young person
should have to go through and what are
the barriers obviously there's the
language barrier but there is also the
cultural and and also there's a moment
in American life right now how do they
see the country in which they're coming
into they're so excited and hopeful and
they see the United States as an
opportunity so you know because they've
been through extreme circumstances no
one wants to leave their home no one
wants to do that they're they're forced
to leave wherever they're from whether
immigrants or refugees and so they come
to the United States with this hope that
it's going to be somehow different and I
continue to hear that from the students
they're like this is my chance this is
where I I have an opportunity to have
dreams and to actually achieve those
dreams and so they're extremely focused
and they want to learn and they want to
be here and it's amazing what are you
focused on in this next year with this
title and this new set of
responsibilities no I definitely want to
share my students stories because I
think it's it's vitally important
especially right now but I want to
encourage people to have experiences
outside of their understanding and I
want educators to provide students with
that opportunity because we fear what we
don't understand and so experience is
really really important and so that's
what I'm advocating Wednesday empathy
yes well when she was back in the green
and people are shaking her hand going
you're a teacher and everybody can name
a teacher that they said changed their
lives or had a big impact on them so I'm
curious about what it is that you that
excites you most about the job that you
do first she said backstage and
everybody gasp I love teenagers love
teenagers I definitely thought I mean
they're going you know I mean I don't
know if you remember but I remember
demanding yeah like thought-process
season like this everything is new like
from the time you're a child to you know
even now I mean really ever there's new
stuff but um the thing that I love the
most about teenagers is that there's so
much possibility all the time and life
hasn't yet it really it hasn't yet
happened they think so in the moment and
that's also like awesome to watch but
you know there's so much ahead and just
that potential is so exciting and my
favorite thing is building relationships
with students and connecting and getting
to know them on a personal level that
it's it's just it's such a it's such a
pleasure it's such an honor to be able
to do that with that's an honor to meet
you
yeah and congratulations you've
certainly made a difference Mandy
Manning with a very cool name and the
very cool haircut thank you very much
for coming to the table today